we'll have new information this morning
about a former investigator for Special
Counsel Robert Muller now being
investigated by the FBI agent Peter
struck was marched out of the bureau's
offices on Friday after an inspector
general's report revealed more
anti-trump text messages that struck
scent while working on the Hillary
Clinton email probe Paula Reid is at the
FBI headquarters in Washington with more
on this story Paula good morning good
morning structs attorney tells me that
struck will fight to keep his job here
at the FBI
even though Republican lawmakers and an
independent watchdog have accused him of
tainting two of the biggest political
investigations in US history the techs
are there you can read them you have to
be an idiot not to realize they're
totally biased late Tuesday night
president Trump's lawyer Rudy Giuliani
slammed the Justice Department about
politically charged text messages
between FBI agent Peter Strahm and
former FBI lawyer Lisa Paige the
investigators now need to be
investigated if we're gonna see justice
here on Capitol Hill Tuesday Republican
lawmakers grilled Justice Department
Inspector General Michael Horowitz about
the FBI's handling of the Clinton email
probe February March 2 2016 Peter struck
said Trump's abysmal Trump's an idiot
he's a bleep an idiot Hillary should win
a hundred million to zero sounds to me
like he hates the president his text
messages would certainly leave that as
the implication struck and Paige worked
on both the Clinton email case and the
investigation into Russian interference
in the 2016 campaign they were then
assigned to the special counsels team
but were removed when the texts were
discovered Paige has since left the FBI
the Inspector General has recommended
struck and Paige her disciplinary
proceedings over their text messages
along with three other FBI employees he
declines to publicly name the president
also seized on the text messages let me
tell you we got some bad people that are
doing bad things he feels terrible about
it
strux attorney Aiden Goldman says his
client is devastated that his own words
are being used to undermine the FBI Pete
would be the first to admit that it was
a mistake to send these texts I mean he
sent them and with
expectation that they would remain
private struck has agreed to testify
before Congress without immunity and
without invoking the Fifth Amendment and
I asked his lawyer
why mr. struck would agree to such a
public and likely very bruising hearing
and he told me that his client wants a
chance to tell his story and does not
want to allow Republicans to paint him
or his actions unfairly Nora Paula
thinks I mean a very serious story but
you hear the lawyer saying he thought
these were gonna remain private well
yeah that's the problem
it's 2018 and Louie these things are all
at once you type it it's there even when
you hit delete you know that